evangelische schule neukölln achte
klasse vor wenigen tagen sie bereiten
sich auf die bundestagswahl
ist christian lindner von der fdp dass
er für reiche
und
wieder grün und die bemerkt klimas die
jugendlichen machen sich bereits jetzt
gedanken über ihre zukunft
[Musik]
finden und das sollte auf jeden fall
gewässert werden und mit der umwelt
natürlich auch bei sonst deshalb meine
zukunft vor einer woche ein schulraum
wird zum wahllokal die stimmberechtigten
zeigen ihre ausweise erhalten einen
stimmzettel und machen ihr kreuzchen es
ist fast wie bei der bundestagswahl doch
hier darf nur wählen denn noch nicht
volljährig ist es sind 18 elisa und lola
gehen in die elfte klasse und haben sich
als wahlhelferinnen gemeldet ihnen ist
wichtig die meinung derer sichtbar
machen die noch kein wahlrecht haben
ich denke dass
jüngere vielmehr repräsentiert werden
müssen weil
haben die klimapolitik wird ja dann eher
effekte für die jüngeren haben gerade
die menschen die vielleicht das klingt
jetzt etwas gemeint aber noch zehn jahre
auf diesem planeten so denke ich nicht
dass die den klimawandel so auf dem
bildschirm haben sondern eher an
wirtschaft und denkt mit ihren
kritischen fragen konfrontieren die
jugendlichen auch die neuköllner direkt
kandidaten und kandidatinnen wann
gedenkt denn ihre partei
klimaneutralität für deutschland zu
schaffen wurde ihrer meinung nach die
digitalisierung verschlafen sie leben ja
die unterhaltung ab und mit nieten
deckel ab und sie sagen das neue bauen
die lösung ist ist das nicht eine sehr
langfristige lösungen die politikerinnen
und politiker nehmen die kluft zwischen
den generationen war bei den jüngeren
ist einfach die veränderungsbereitschaft
viel viel höher als bei sehr vielen
älteren menschen daher schon bei vielen
auch die bedenken vor was das für sie
persönlich bedeuten würde wenn sich
jetzt viel verändert raste stimme für
angehört aber stimmen auszählen
bundesweit beteiligten sich über
260.000 jugendliche an der u18 wahl ein
rekordergebnis die schülerinnen und
schüler wären auch für eine
bundestagswahl gut vorbereitet findet
lehrer martin schneider es gibt auch
jede menge erwachsene die politisch sage
ich mal unreif sind oder unkritisch und
gar nicht genau sich damit beschäftigen
was sie stimmen das bedeutet natürlich
nicht dass man ihnen das wahlrecht ab
erkennt aber es bedeutet auch dass
16-jährige durchaus in der lage sind
mündig zu sein und abzustimmen am tag
nach der bundestagswahl auch in diesem
jahr durften sie wieder nur zuschauen
und die ergebnisse der u18 bei mit der
bundestagswahl vergleichen dort sind die
grünen dritter bei der u18 wahl liegen
sie vorn gefolgt von spd und union
und das ist einfach andere parteien
andere interessen vertreten ich denke
der friseur zu gehen werden wenn die
jungen leute während werden warum weil
sie sich halt auch fürs klima
fokussieren dass bei den jungen menschen
einfach das haupt der hauptpunkt ist
momentan dann sieht man freilich for
future und auch mit einem forderungen
die gemacht werden von den jungen
menschen und die grünen die sind halt
dort am stärksten
2025 zählen ihre stimmen trotzdem werden
sie in der minderheit sein der konflikt
zwischen alt und jung wird bleiben